HAVE ONE BILL BUT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL. GLAZER
LATER HERE CHIANG. CHING HERE
ARE TO LET YOUR PARTULIDAE HERE
DODD GALGIANI HILL GALGIANI
HERE HILL. LEYVA PAN PAN HERE
WILK. THANK YOU LISTA SAID WE
HAVE ONE BILL OWNER FILE TODAY
THAT WAS AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND PERCENT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY NINE POINT TEN DE
IS UP FOR CONSIDERATION. THE
THEME CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VICE CHAIR I'D MEMBERS. SB
SIX OH NINE IS THE SUNSET BILL
FOR THE BUREAU OF SECURITY AND
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY
INCREASE THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATOR FEES IN ACCORDANCE
WITH AN EXTERNAL AUDIT AND AT
THE REQUEST OF THE BUREAU.
WITHOUT THE PROPOSED FEE
INCREASE THE PRIVATE
INVESTIGATIVE ACCOUNT IS
PROJECTED TO BECOME INSOLVENT.
THIS FISCAL YEAR. ADDITIONALLY
SB SIX OH NINE MERGES THE
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR FUND. AND
THE PRIVATE SECURITY SERVICES
FUND. IT ALIGNS THE BUREAU
STATUTES WITH THE PENAL CODE.
AND MAKES VARIOUS OTHER CHANGES
STEMMING FROM THE SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT CONDUCTED BY THIS
AGENCY. THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
THAT I'M AWARE OF AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHAT THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS BY MEMBERS THE BILL.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED MISTER
CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION FOR ALL OF OUR
WORK ON THE SUNSET BILLS THIS
YEAR IT'S A PART OF OUR
OBLIGATION AS A COMMITTEE AND
WE LEARNED A LOT DURING IT AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF HELP FROM OUR
STAFF FROM OUR BUREAUS AND WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF.
THE MOTION BY SENATOR PAN. THIS
CALL THE ROLL. QUESTION IS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AND AMEND SPEAKING
CURTAIN GLAZER. GLAZER I CHANGE
BY. CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I DOT. DODD AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL BY
HILL AYE LEYVA PAN ALL RIGHT
CAN I WILK ALL RIGHT OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA WOULD LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER
. BUT EIGHT ZERO. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA CALL THAT BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE BACK
TO ORDER WE HAVE ONE BILL
THAT'S ON CALL SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL ON SB SIX OH NINE.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE. THAT BILLS OUT
NINE ZERO AND WITH THAT ARE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED